yes going to welcome to this video l
your for the new opponent let's see
English opening like to avoid the trade
to them keeps a little bit more tension
on the board
okay I think I'm going to put this on d5
and to change the pawn structure so that
a pawn will appeal and d5 at least in
most cases this will be happening 95
Bishop g7 e has 93 to avoid this
surprise that he actually is sorry
invest some time in night XD five looks
like the only sensible okay here white
should have a slight edge so what to do
Queens greedy to Lester normal kind of
cell
I'm just going to centralize him they
should hope like a set the knight on d5
is just sitting there and he can never
go e 6 h4 h5 is a very typical way off
i'm trying to go to create more
weaknesses yeah Queen h6 is already
possible so let's go there it seems that
is out for night at five I can go a form
preventing this I wonder i'm not
entirely sure about it but i think it's
probably worth doing
yeah let's go here f4 could be a threat
I'm not entirely sure him a form 94
takes he at least cannot take with the
Queen as 93 7 is made he's some probably
avoiding this scenario with rupee eight
I mean that's wrong he is definitely
avoiding the scenario the thing is what
i meant as he's really playing against
this idea luckily one would threaten f4
maybe
oh maybe I still do it come on let's
let's play this it's an aggressive way
Queen will take of course pawn takes us
assistance totally wrong and my ideas f5
threatening f5 here then look therefore
would actually trap the Queen so um if
it takes a couple of times I can take in
seven at the end I'm not sure what this
is actually I will be seven the strong
at the end I think okay let's do it GTX
it takes Knight takes a try blue back
five queen at five rook takes these
seven I think this is strong the
threatens look takes the edge rook takes
the 89 f six winning the Queen this is
not going to be easily send it off I
don't see how yeah so look at five king
and queen takes Andrew p7 how are you
not losing everything there there is a
check on t2 where I can go to h1 I ok
well the hook is only seven then is
there anything else that I could do
so this is chick shoot the chick is
really putting a spanner in the works
can always check on the light square
sphere it's really lucky that this works
Jim it's unfortunate I guess I have to
okay yeah created such it's a draw ah
come on that's it's it's a really
unlucky in that this is a draw at least
I think it's at all Quincy to i think is
a perpetual what can i do something else
when it's a perpetual King h3n Queen f5
is isidro okay yeah but that's
unfortunate my thread is to take and
neither six wins the Queen he has I
don't think he has anything else than
making the draw now was it pretty pretty
oops this one time won't shoot okay this
is purely playing on time of course it's
objectively terrible but he continues
again at least I think it's objectively
terrible i could be wrong
[Music]
ok
rah offered to eject connection problem
there yeah winning is difficult him
after now think i'll take it i mean ok
i'm winning here in fact but with the
King coming to g5 you have the time
irritated me huh ok interesting so I'm
be an agency should just make the draw
and we was playing for lost their
actually so f five and five ah wow
that's an interesting move here given by
the comp oh please try to fight for six
in this way sorry B takes a txt six huh
Wow Ray's got this one place where the
engine gives this move and I think it's
funny that it only gives a plus one so
there's some kind of ending the slight
advantage concludes completely inhuman
line okay I took their and now I think
after this we have this drawing okay yes
to draw now I mean what you played is
just trying for a loss or maybe on time
I don't know it completely unnecessary I
we have this is not playing for winning
ever yeah yeah because I mean I can
always check him and I material of him I
am so in the end time action and winning
which I did not understand I was too
worried about the time situation yeah
actually this is the key point yet I can
i get to g5 when my king is save also
[Music]
he knew I shouldn't take it wrong he's
got no decent movie maybe I should have
thought from moment at least before i
took this amy interesting stuff
nonetheless thanks for watching